[Música]
só sejam bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer com um
tanque com o número é bastante fácil
isso tem que andar para frente para trás
para os lados e ainda dispara ea melhor
parte é que vocês vão conseguir fazer
isso em casa se tiverem dois motores que
eram a mesma velocidade e depois se
quiserem que o bastante para também vão
precisar do motor dirigir muito devagar
têm alguma força com e sei que vocês vão
ver mais para frente um tutorial
por isso o mais difícil depois será
encontrar uma carta protesto aqui você
não tiver em casa podem tentar usar um
material parecido mas temos tempo barato
você consegue encontrar nas lojas de
carpete vão lá e corta em 50 centímetros
e já vai dar para fazer uns 45 tempos e
o comando também muito simples eu usei
para me furto picolé ou seja políticos
do lado molas e alguns carros agora isso
parece confuso mas é muito simples de
vocês vão perceber no tutorial
agora vamos começar a entender que os
outros pensam como eu vou te parar aqui
você perde uma bola quando eu aqui de
pára por aí
agora vamos descansar para lá
[Música]
ae
é isso
[Música]
frans hals que no fim espero que vocês
tenham gostado deste projecto eu
pessoalmente adorarei porque é fácil e é
muito divertido
aí peço desculpa não ter feito as falas
ao longo do tutorial mas esta semana
estou com um pouco de pressa tentar
gravar três vídeos por parece não gostar
outra vez fora
depois quando eu voltar eu vou ler as
vossas sugestões e continuarão como
fazia antigamente passageiro com as
falas do tutorial
então isso aí muito melhor ter sido até
a próxima já está bom porque eu não
tenho uma carrada de coisas de lado e
acabar com o ego